il m'avait marqué c'était mon prof de
danse pendant un petit moment mais non
ici parce qu'il est d'alsace il est prof
de danse en alsace est paré belles
heures de les montrer ce qu'ils ont
appris
[Applaudissements]
en fait il ya quelques années la tma
peut pas danser non j'ai participé au
casting de danse avec les stars
et du coup pour mettre toutes les
chances de me coller
des cours voilà j'ai joué j'ai pris ça
n'a pas suffi
mais oui vous n'aviez pas dit cette
histoire le racontez vous êtes vous avez
vous voir pour participer à danse avec
l'espoir tout à fait et au final c'est
elodie gossuin foule et demi j'ai
commencé voilà parce que chacun et
chacune
c'était l'année où elodie a été casté et
j'ai été casté ça vous ça vous ça vous
aurait plu à j'adore et éventuellement
la cire venez vous voir est-ce que vous
iriez vous diriez oui à nouveau pourquoi
pas non mais c'est vrai nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui est ça le seuil tout ça va
chauffer
alors autant delphine elle est
exceptionnelle elle ni quelqu'un
je suis dégueulasse et ma vie repas
aggraverait moi si vous étiez parti
alors on l'avait trouvé le public moins
charmant il était bien pas
[Applaudissements]
ici on se bat on ne dit que la vérité
j'étais achierdi
et commenté delphine way
côté différence de niveau et vous avez
très bien et range de typepad moi c'est
la femme de benjamin gille pour ce
dernier
delphine et droid
life in a failli être candidate de danse
avec les stars mais ben jamais ce qu'il
ne dit pas c'est qu'il a failli animé
danse avec les stars
j'ai refusé ouais mais quand m mais
c'est la soirée derrière je veux tout
savoir s'est offerte à lui n'a pas bien
ta copine de mode 100 pigeons mais ne
l'a pas dit bon je te dis pas tout voilà
le savez n'avait en fait pas ce qu'il
voulait qu'on anime en duo avec flavie
essais on était en quelle année on est
en 2008 mais l'on souhaite et je crois
que tu es divorcée en 2011 en fait
j'adore son ex senna je crois que
c'était un peu un peu compliqué vrillé
2011 c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont proposé je
suis pas sûr c'est qu'ici
on fait quoi ainsi il est proposé de
faire un truc en duo avec sa vie mais
c'était le rsa mais ne s'était d'alice
wings avec les stars alors que des
mutins carrière que toi tu as raison mon
soutien et nous regrette nous pas map
alors pas du tout je trouve l'émission
vraiment pas du tout intéressant tany
meva balala d'accord non mais c'est vrai
que
rien à faire il aurait été bon
[Applaudissements]